do you guys get frustrated in Sacramento
that like people say that
people who aren't from Northern
California just kind of box y'all in
with the Bay Area uh I mean back because
I hear so many people yo we [ __ ] with
debate man I [ __ ] with Mozzy and I'm
like modi's from Sacramento yeah no I
always I'll be the one of the correct
people most of the time but I I don't
get irritated or nothing because it's we
real close and it's the northern cow we
all won as far right in the cup but we
are not debate uh back in the days
probably used to get Phil away because
you know it was just a little certain
[ __ ] it's like we our own [ __ ] right
stop trying to call us the little
brother right be our own big brother or
what a big dog whatever our own [ __ ]
right so that's all it was back then but
over the time [ __ ] that's that and then
at the time that's growing up in school
never left Sacramento never been
anywhere
never met about a real big [ __ ] unless
they come from out here but then you
don't never know so you like never even
left sack when you leave Sacramento
until like Sacramento completely until I
was like because the bay is like only
what two hours away right 15 yeah but I
never went to the Bay right until I was
like 15 my mom moved out there then I
went out there for her but other than
that I never went out there either and
started going out there until I was like
17 18. wow
right Sacramento's you know obviously
you guys are [ __ ] killing it and then
a lot of sweeties from Sacramento
I mean they but they put her on the bay
they go back and forth but yeah I heard
she went to Sacramento High School in
Sacramento yeah
I mean you know shout out to sweetie
she's she's lovely yeah yeah she just
came into the show she smelled great
smelled like a like a candle
good great candle